bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction voici
les titres de ce 9 février 2010 cette
intervention d'envergure sur le réseau
électrique du département à ben 1 km de
lignes équipées de dispositifs anti
paille pour expliciter pardon est les
micro-coupures de cours à prendre la
citoyenneté aux enfants de façon ludique
c'est possible grâce à la maison de la
justice et des droits qui teste un
nouveau jeu des 7 familles et nous irons
à manier les hameaux voir si cela
fonctionne et puis estelle traa et
éleveuse de chevaux à d'avron a lancé
une pétition pour sauver son élevage
suite à une erreur de bayel se retrouve
obligé de quitter le terrain qu'elle
occupe actuellement le journal les échos
vient de publier un classement des 500
champion français de la croissance à la
162ème place de ce palmarès on retrouve
à terre mais c'est une pme qui est
présent sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines et en moyenne elles
affichent un taux de croissance de plus
de 40 6% par an le reportage de nicolas
d'andry une championne de la croissance
à montigny le bretonneux
la pme à terme s affiche un taux moyen
de 46 2% par an une réussite pour cette
entreprise spécialisée dans des produits
de haute technologie destinées aux
industriels de la sécurité défense
cette croissance est due à aux
investissements que nous avons faits en
recherche et développement et
l'accompagnement que nous avons eu quand
même des clients qui nous font confiance
et puis alors à la motivation du
personnel
créé en 1989 cette pme est venu
s'installer à montigny le bretonneux
notamment pour se rapprocher de ses
clients comme thales eads ou mbd à des
donneurs d'ordres exigeant qui nécessite
de la main d'oeuvre très qualifiée est
difficile à trouver
c'est le savoir-faire c'est l'ancienneté
de leur de la société aussi donc sa
pérennité sans savoir faire on a
énormément de collaborateurs extrêmement
compétents nous pourrions embauché à peu
près 10 ou 15 personnes supplémentaires
si on les avait tout de suite par
rapport à notre chiffre d'affaires et à
nos carnets de commandes s'est vraiment
que quoi autre facteur de croissance le
développement de leur propre gamme de
produits à l'export 20% du chiffre
d'affaires est réinvesti dans la
recherche et développement ce qui
représente 6 millions d'euros en 2015
notamment pour développer ce système de
surveillance aux frontières et de sites
stratégiques destinés à l'exportation
dans le marché export très clairement
nous travaillons avec des grands
donneurs d'ordre de la défense notre
client le plus important est un client
chinois qui s'appelle norinco prochaine
étape poursuivre le développement de ses
produits pour passer d'un statut de pme
à celui d'entreprises de taille
intermédiaire on a pris de la hauteur à
ben hier quatre techniciens donner 10
anciennement erdf ont installé des
protections sur les lignes à haute
tension un kilomètre de ligne et est
ainsi équipé d'un dispositif anti paille
qui permet d'éviter les micro-coupures
de courant michael et demi d'euros
matile de 2000 étaient sur place sur le
chantier
dans ces lignes passent 20000 volts un
réseau électrique alimentant ben et les
communes avoisinantes
ce matin quatre techniciens
interviennent sur un kilomètre de ligne
c'est un chantier d'y tester donc
réalisé sous tension se dire que la
ligne est maintenu sous tension et donc
l'opération consiste à poser ce qu'on
appelle des dispositifs anti paille donc
pour éviter que les fétu de paille ne
touche la ligne et les férus oh le
poteau en même temps ce qui provoquerait
des courts-circuits et donc des
microcoupures pour nos clients
de la paille projetés lors des moissons
ou de grands vents le dispositif c'est
ça une sorte de pince à linge
m'installer à 13 mètres de hauteur ils
ont une jauge graduée c'est notre
distance à respecter donc faut pas qu'on
s'approche ce qu'on appelle à plus de 6o
paie donc les opc des éléments de
protection est un élément de protection
correspond à 10 cm donc en montant faut
qu'on respecte nous s'ils se paie donc
60 cm par rapport à la ligne qui est
sous tension donc en permanence ils
surveillent leur leurs mouvements et
leurs distances par rapport au réseau
des dispositifs de protection des
oiseaux ont aussi été installés les
yvelines compte 5000 km de lignes
électriques 700 sont aériennes
l' axe est emprunté tous les jours par
plusieurs milliers de véhicules il sera
bientôt encore plus avec l'arrivée de
500 nouveaux logements sur le quartier
de la remise le carrefour de la rd 36 et
la venue de la pyramide à voisins le
bretonneux actuellement modifié pour
être testés l'ordre des feux et leur
durée sont notamment changer cette phase
de test devrait durer jusqu'à la mi
avril
écoutez les précisions est de bernard
meyer c'est le vice-président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui est en charge de la voirie
par rapport à trois semaines c'est à
dire que le tourne à gauche en
provenance de deux trappes ici a été
supprimée avec un la simulation d'un
rond point central qui est juste
derrière nous et c'est le principal le
principal événement sachant que le
tourne à gauche en provenance donc de
château fort qui vient de notre droite
lui va rester tout doux mois dans cette
phase il va forcément y avoir des
adaptations à à terme c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont en test social le nombre de
bénéficiaires du rsa a stagné dans les
yvelines et cela impacte les finances du
département qui le prend en charge en
partie nous allons faire le point à
présent avec nicolas gandrille tout
d'abord petit rappel le revenu de
solidarité active a été lancé en 2009
pour remplacer le rmi
cette allocation assure un revenu
minimum en général à des personnes de
plus de 25 ans même si dans certaines
conditions on peut en bénéficier à
partir de 18 ans dans les yvelines le
rsa moyen d'une personne célibataire
s'élève à 470 euros par mois
une somme nettement en dessous de la
moyenne nationale qui atteint les 535
euros mensuels prenons d'abord le nombre
de bénéficiaires du rsa dans le
département des yvelines en décembre
2014 ils étaient près de 22000 600
allocataires du rsa ils sont 23 1401 en
2015 soit une augmentation de 3 5% en un
an
la tendance semble s'inverser pour
l'année 2016 au 30 septembre preuve plus
de 21 mille personnes blessés
bénéficient de cette allocation ce qui
représente une baisse de 10%
concernant les montants alloués par la
caf en 2014 112,1 millions d'euros ont
été versés au titre du rsa
une somme en nette augmentation en 2015
avec 124 7 millions d'euros soit 10% de
plus en 2016 la tendance est à la baisse
avec 122,3 millions d'euros distribués
ce qui représente une diminution de 2%
alors il faut savoir que ces fonds sont
transférés par le conseil départemental
à la caf et on retrouve une partie de
ces montants dans le budget du
département consacré au rsa et à
l'insertion 141,9 millions votés en 2016
et 146,9 millions d'euros prévus pour
l'année 2010 est alors pour soutenir les
départements et compenser le transfert
des compétences au niveau des aides
sociales
l'état verse chaque année une dotation
aux collectivités départementales elle
est en baisse c'est derrière nous ces
dernières années selon les représentants
des collectivités
est ce que le département des yvelines
sort de sa poche ne cesse d'augmenter
comme vous le voyez à l'écran près de 40
millions d'euros en 2015 jusqu'à plus de
65 millions prévus pour 2017
à ce sujet je vous propose d'écouter
laurent richard il est président de la
commission des finances au conseil
départemental des yvelines
c'est l'état qui n'augmente pas sa de sa
dotation de compensation à ce niveau là
qui nous impose un coût plus élevé
puisque le rsa lui aussi de son son sa
valeur je vire à augmenter sa valeur
nominale augmenter progressivement et
bien sûr le nombre de demandeurs
effectivement augmente mais beaucoup
moins ki moon aurait augmenté si nous
y ont pas pris des mesures de contrôle
et d'intégration dans le cadre de sa
politique d'insertion le département des
yvelines a créé l' agence activity en
sa mission préparer les bénéficiaires du
rsa à une réinsertion sur le marché du
travail en collaboration avec des
institutions comme pôle emploi ou
d'autres institutions de la collectivité
je vous propose d'écouter le directeur
d'activité philippe pascal au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude
on a développé tout ce qui est clause
d'insertion
c'est à dire quelle que soit la commune
qui fait un appel à projets en appel
d'offres plus tôt on y met des clauses
d'insertion et non my tout le territoire
la chance avec des facilitatrice des
facilitateurs pour justement accompagner
les collectivités territoriales est
aussi accompagnée des entreprises qui
ont répondu ou qui ont obtenu le marché
pour travailler avec eux sur quels sont
leurs besoins
à quel type de métier ils ont besoin on
s'est fixé en chiffres sur 2016 2017
5000 bénéficiaires du rsa qui ont quitté
le dispositif du rsa selon les données
transmises par activity pour l'année
2016 près de 2800 bénéficiaires du rsa
on retrouvait une formation ou un cdi ou
un cdd
nous poursuivons ce journal à présent
estate hre a arrêté levée de chevaux à
d'avron elle a lancé une pétition pour
sauver son élevage et suite à une erreur
de bayel se retrouve obligé de quitter
le terrain avec elle occupe actuellement
avec elle ses 40 chevaux et terrain
qu'elle occupe depuis maintenant huit
ans le problème elle n'a trouvé aucun
autre lieu pour l'accueillir elle sera
probablement expulsés le reportage de
camille lambert
comme tous les jours estelle s'occupe de
ses protégés cela fait huit ans qu'il a
monté son élevage de chevaux elle se
lance en 2009 loup 4 hectares de prés un
particulier et installe une petite
cabane pour le matériel un rêve devenu
réalité mais aujourd'hui menacé le
bailleur était même trajet un homme très
gentil
et ça se passe extrêmement bien pendant
deux ans et puis au moment de son décès
c'est sa femme qui a repris
l'exploitation et du coup elle a
souhaité que je parte je suis expulsé
par après décision de justice tribunal
paritaire des baux ruraux
donc je suis condamné à partir de là aux
chevilles
après cette décision en décembre 2015
estelle se met en quête d'un autre
terrain pour accueillir ces 40 chevaux
de sport et poneys de loisirs elle fait
appel à la safer d'île de france mais
aucune de ces candidatures n'est retenu
pour alerter sur sa situation elle fait
une grève de la faim pendant dix jours
et un collectif de soutien voit le jour
là collectif a lancé la pétition en
ligne pour essayer de toucher un maximum
de gens et pour a essayé d'alerter les
pouvoirs publics oui j'avais démarré une
dalle de la fin j'ai été contrainte
d'arrêter pour raisons médicales mais
que si j'avais je ne vois que ça bouge
pas je serai prête à reprendre malgré
tout cela banon je vois pas d'issue
favorable pour moi si ce n'est à terme
une disparition de l'élevage si je ne
retrouve pas de terrain
aujourd'hui dans l'impasse estelle
redoute d'être expulsée d'une semaine à
l'autre
une situation qui touche également sa
fille impliquée dans l'élevage
j'aimerais surtout que des personnes se
rendent compte de la situation
qu' il puisse nous aider mais moi si je
fais mon futur travail qui sera en kung
que et maintenant alliant un peu mon
problème contacté par nos soins
l'avocate de la propriétaire ne peut
donner suite à notre demande d'interview
lancée il ya deux semaines la pétition a
déjà recueilli plus de 1600 signatures
et pour conclure ce journal nous allons
voir qu'à prendre la citoyenneté aux
enfants de façon ludique c'est possible
grâce à la maison de la justice et des
droits et qui teste un nouveau jeu des 7
familles santé justice sécurité ou
encore école est élue ce sont des
nouvelles familles qui permettent aux
enfants de s'instruire tout en s'amusant
bien évidemment première partie de
cartes avec ce jeu de citoyenneté dans
une école élémentaire c'est ta manière
que je pourrai voir le 3
descartes une pioche
plusieurs groupes ses élèves de cp ce1
ce2 jouer au jeu des 7 familles et un
jeu un peu différent puisqu'il a été
pensé par deux juristes et contient de
nouvelles cartes
on sait respirer de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
était signant 89 ratifiant peut-être les
neuf et on voulait vraiment leur montrer
que ce n'était pas juste des droits des
devoirs mais c'était aussi droit de
s'amuser le droit d'être soigné
voilà le droit d'avoir un travail
c'était un jeu ludique qui a été breveté
par l'agglomération pour faire découvrir
plus facilement la citoyenneté aux
enfants c'est l'école rosa-bonheur qui a
expérimenté pour la première fois ce jeu
en classe c'était quand même bien de
bien intéressant ils ont commencé à
faire attention à ce qui se passe et
faire attention aux échanges faire
attention aux mots qui circulait donc
c'était pas mal ça a pris un petit peu
le travail de groupe
en dehors du vocabulaire donc il y avait
pas mal de choses qui étaient à
exploiter exploitables comprendre les
mots apprendre de nouveaux métiers et
savoir différencier les droits des
devoirs
c'est ce que les élèves ont appris
durant la session du jeu c'est des
métiers qui sont dans la vraie vie
lavez le médecin la gt chose pour
sécurité l'avait déchausse la vt d'un
disque et prend soin autant un outil
pédagogique qui sera distribué à toutes
les écoles volontaires dans le
département des yvelines
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal on se
retrouve lundi dans la bonne humeur pour
une nouvelle édition et demain vendredi
ce sera nicolas kirillovitch pour
l'hebdo
[Musique]